[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 23 mai bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 26 minutes
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
et régionale
les titres de cette édition
l'inauguration hier de classe celle
laboratoire elancourt le projet bouge ta
classe a été lancée à l'école
élémentaire de la commanderie un espace
pédagogique innovant pour apprendre
autrement dans ses seuls enfants pour
être assis debout ou encore allongée
explication dans ce journal est long
cours qui accueille demain la troisième
édition de ski robe un challenge de
codage et de robotique à destination des
jeunes qui se déroule au prisme pour en
parler avec l'air lebed pilote du projet
et anne capio conseillère communautaire
de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis les premières livraisons sont
prévues pour 2020 le projet d'habitat
participatif tintamarre suit son cours à
la verrière il regroupera dix sept
logements autour d'une mare nous
recevons de futurs habitants hassan
camaret pascaline rodier avant de
développer à ses titres à la suite de la
grève à la sncf
11e phase du mouvement en pointillés des
cheminots est directement impactée par
la mobilisation les utilisateurs vont
pouvoir se faire rembourser 50% du passe
navigo pour les mois d'avril et mai
annonce ce matin de la présidente ait
l'air de la région valérie pécresse ces
remboursements concerneront uniquement
les usagers des lignes franciliennes de
la sncf
un site est dédié sera ouvert à la mi
juin pour effectuer sa demande de
dédommagement
côté trafic les perturbations vont se
poursuivre demain à saint quentin en
yvelines pour la journée de jeudi ce
sont les mêmes prévisions qu'aujourd'hui
la moitié des trains circuleront 1 train
sur 2 pour tous les axes qui concerne le
territoire le rer c et les lignes n ai
eu du transilien les dernières
informations sont à consulter sur le
site transilien.com une retraite
annoncée à 49 ans david douillet va
quitter la vie politique
il l'a confirmé dans une interview à nos
confrères du parisien l actuel président
de la fédération les républicains des
yvelines ne sera pas candidat à sa
succession en octobre et l'élu va tout
de même terminé son mandat de conseiller
régional
heller qui court jusqu'en 2021 et david
douillet se dit déçu par certains cadres
du parti et ne partage pas la ligne
actuelle de son président national
laurent wauquiez au cours de sa carrière
l'ancien judoka aura briguer notamment
les sièges de député des yvelines
secrétaire d'état ministre des sports
sous les gouvernements fillon le
président du département des yvelines
pierre bédier la conseillère régionale
alexandra dublanche notamment sont en
course pour prendre la tête de l air 78
à elancourt l'inauguration donc mardi
soir du projet bouge ta classe 10
classes pilotes dans six écoles
élémentaires dispose notamment de
nouveaux espaces pédagogiques une
évolution sur la façon d'appréhender
l'espace terminé le tableau noir et les
rangées de pupitres les détails avec
wilfrid richy et patrick jacques de
dixmude repenser réaménager ses salles
de classe de l'école élémentaire de la
commanderie à elle en cours doivent
permettre de faciliter les enseignements
ne cherchez plus les bancs ni l'estrade
et son tableau ici l'on peut s'asseoir
confortablement l on peut même circulé
pendant les cours un enfant de 10 ans
n'est pas fait pour rester pendant six
heures assis devant une table
il a besoin de bouger il ya des postures
et donc ça ça lui permet de changer de
posture et de mieux se concentrer
ayé 2 de prendre l'acte d'apprendre
comme du plaisir donc c'est important
il a plusieurs sites il peut changer ils
changent exercice
c'est ce qui renouvelle ses stimuli et
qui augmente sa concentration et donc sa
mémorisation et donc ses résultats
scolaires
les évolutions ne s'arrête pas là
puisque usages des tablettes des robots
ou de la visioconférence tonnes mieux un
avant goût de l'école du futur
ces classes repenser sont le résultat
d'un travail mené depuis dix ans avec
les outils numériques on est obligé
d'apprendre autrement avec une autre
posture
donc on a fait un concours par les
enseignants en leur demandant d'imaginer
leur place autrement avec les outils
numériques
ce qu'ils ont fait la société manutan
s'est ensuite chargé de concrétiser les
idées pour les résultats les enseignants
notent déjà un encadrement simplifiée
des élèves en difficulté et une plus
grande autonomie des plus aguerris
ce qui devrait permettre de généraliser
ces changements aux autres écoles de la
ville et dans les autres communes une
tentative supplémentaire de remonter au
classement pisa qui évalue les
performances des systèmes scolaires dans
le monde
la finlande figure de modèle en matière
de nouvelles classes il pointe au 5e
rang
la france est actuellement 25e on l'a vu
dans ce sujet ces capitaux bonsoir elle
vous est 2è maire-adjoint d'elancourt à
l'éducation à l'école numérique au
périscolaire conseillère communautaire
de saint quentin en yvelines également
conseillère départementale alors vous
êtes venus pour parler d'autre chose
avec un clair le belmont soir ça vous
êtes proviseur adjoint du lycée 17 mar à
maurepas pilote du projet ski robe sur
le bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
alors le troisième challengeuse kirop se
déroule demain jeudi au prisme
d'elancourt c'est un challenge de codage
et de robotique inter degré
expliquez-nous un peu le principe de ski
robe alors le challenge la journée
demain et le final du projet qui est un
projet annuel
c'est un projet qui fédère les classes
autour de la programmation du codage sa
réponse
de manière réelle ou aux programmes de
l'éducation nationale inter degré
puisque on accueille des maternelles ou
lycée donc soit les classes de tous
niveaux et de tous niveaux il ya
quarante classes 30 établissements sur
toute l'agglomération de saint quentin
et vous en avez dit deux mots c'est un
travail qui s'est fait sur une année
finalement ça sera la finalité c'est un
travail pluridisciplinaire qui permet
d'aborder le codage la robotique nos si
les mathématiques la logique l'art
plastique et l'art visuel le français
puisque tout le monde doit travailler
toute l'année donc les professeurs
travaillent en collaboration en
mutualisant leurs pratiques
tout au long de l'année et demain c'est
le final alors ce challenge est financé
en grande partie par saint quentin en
yvelines 80 % 20 % par la ville
d'elancourt à une capio pourquoi est ce
important pour l'agglomération et pour
la ville d'elancourt d'investir sur la
robotique pourquoi la robotique est elle
un sujet important
alors en fait la jeunesse de ceux de ce
challenge a eu lieu il ya quatre ans
puisqu'ils avaient eu lieu il ya quatre
ans à l'initiative de la ville
d'elancourt puisque le maire d'elancourt
et le président de la communauté
d'agglomération jean michel brousse et
très connecté sur ces sujets et saint
quentin a décidé de faire de son
territoire un territoire numérique et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle bon
cette année l'éducation nationale a
repris ce projet mais saint quentin en
yvelines a souhaité être partenaire de
ce projet pour prouver la volonté d de
saint quentin sur les territoires de
faire un territoire numérique et
notamment au niveau des écoles on l'a
dit vous êtes élue elle encourt la
hausse ont mis en place depuis plusieurs
années des tablettes numériques dans les
écoles des robots également la robotique
le numérique plus globalement
en quoi sont ils intéressants dans
l'éducation à votre avis
alors là ce serait peut-être plus tôt à
la spécialiste de l'éducation de d'en
parler mais c'est vrai que les retours
que l'on à des enseignants sur sur ses
pratiques de codage informatique c'est
plus de concentration plus de confiance
en soi
et puis quand on programme ont enfin
sous contrôle de même les bêtes mais
quand on travaille sur un projet de
programmation numérique
on collabore on discute on
on travaille ensemble et c'est important
oui la robotique finalement c'est très
transversal ça va nécessiter des
connaissances aussi bien en
mathématiques en langage aussi géométrie
voilà gérer l'espace ça permet d'aborder
toutes sortes d'éléments du programme
cette fois de manière concrète et réelle
ça permet d'avoir des experts donc les
professeurs qui arrive qui qui
présentent leur discipline de façon
réelle ce qui est beaucoup plus motivant
ce qui permet aussi donc on est
extrêmement un terrain degrés mais ce
qui permet aussi du travail collaboratif
entre les professeurs du même
établissement où entre établissements
alors comment ça va se dérouler
concrètement demain on l'a dit des
classes réparties en équipe comment
comment va se dérouler cette journée
alors s'interroge en quatre phases des
phases à peu près des tranches d'âge qui
nous réunit les cycles de les cycles 3
ce qui nous permet déjà de faire la
liaison maternelles élémentaires
une deuxième phase de ces deux phases de
deux heures chaque fois qu'ils
accueillent à peu près 200 élèves
d'accord
la deuxième phase c'est les cycles 3
donc du film de la sixième on retrouvait
la liaison inter degré écoles
élémentaires collèges
l'après midi on arrive avec les plus
grands donc là on a le cyclo 4
donc ils ont aussi travaillé des
compétences du brevet à ce niveau là et
la dernière phase les lycées qui nous
permettent de travailler aussi là la
liaison troisième seconde
quels sont les critères d'évaluation
qu'est-ce qui va départager finalistes
qui va départager vécu alors déjà ils
ont eu toute une partie qui est déjà été
évaluées sur le travail de publication
qui a eu lieu tout au long de l'année
sur le blog
donc ça déjà le nombre d'évaluations le
nombre de productions la qualité et la
richesse des médias qui sont posées on
écrit en français correctement mais
c'est mieux quand en effet quand on
produit puis demain donc les jurys
nombreuses et variées puisque à des
jurys d'entreprise des jurys de la
communauté d'agglo de la ville des
enseignants vont démarrer vraiment
évaluer la programmation le codage si
les capteurs sont utilisés s'il ya des
boucles 6 à des algorithmes
à chaque fois c'est évalué en fonction
de la tranche d'âge et donc des
programmes mais c'était programme
éducation nationale par robotique qui
les enfants les compétences que les
enfants doivent acquérir et elle capture
c'est un événement important qui va
arriver pour saint quentin en yvelines
fin septembre la ryder cup cette année
pour ce challenge le fil conducteur
s'était justement la ryder cup
voilà on a trouvé ce thème avec avec
claire qu'il était intéressant de
développer ce thème de la ryder cup donc
le parcours que les enfants ont eu dans
le cahier des charges qui sera le même
pour tout le monde avec des difficultés
différentes selon les niveaux
c'est un parcours qui a été réalisée je
tiens le site allait à lui elle précisé
par les animateurs des centres de
loisirs de la ville d'elancourt à qui on
a donné le cahier des charges et qui
nous ont gentiment préparé le parcours
enfants avec avec les enfants dans les
centres de loisirs ça a été aussi une
activité toute mon année nous robots
sont aussi customiser donc par les
professeurs d'arts plastiques forme de
robot golfeur
voilà d'un robot de base lorsqu'on est
ce qu'on obtient et ça aussi c'est
évaluer et donc tout sera sera à voir
demain demain jeudi le 3e challenge ski
rohff se déroule donc au prisme des
longs courts essais de 9h à 18h merci à
vous deux capio et et à claire le bret
d'avoir été avec nous le bet pardon
d'avoir été avec nous et vous pouvez
retrouvez plus d'informations sur cet
événement sur le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran lui vs cul dans le top 15
des universités françaises c'est un
palmarès international qui le dit le
classement turcs eurent à place
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines à la 15e position nationale une
progression une progression de quatre
places depuis l'an passé eu rapt tient
compte des activités académiques de
l'établissement nombre de publications
dans le web of science nombre de
citations échos publications
internationales au niveau mondial uv sql
336e d'après ce palmarès c'est l'un des
tout premiers en france poissy a
inauguré hier mercredi un puits
aujourd'hui mercredi par dont un puits
de carbone le système et écologique il
purifie l'air à partir du co2 dégagé
notamment par les voitures
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
le quartier de la gare de poissy devrait
à mieux respirer la ville a inauguré ce
mercredi 22 mai un puits de carbone le
premier des yvelines objectif de ce
dispositif lancé après deux ans
d'expérimentation lutter contre la
pollution atmosphérique notamment le co2
dégagées par les voitures
le principe est le principe de la
photosynthèse on prend de l'air vicié
que l'on injecte dans la colonne dans
cette colonne nous avons mis de l'eau et
des microalgues que nous éclairons
continue
le fait de combiner les clairement plus
pollution d'un air vicié les micro
algues vont capter cet air vicié se
reproduire et purifier l'air ainsi le
totem de deux mètres cinquante a été
loué par la ville de poissy jusqu'à
l'année prochaine pour une période de
test coût total de l'opération 20000
euros la commune espère également
sensibiliser les passants sur
l'environnement nous aimerions que les
gens se posent la question parce qu'un
aspect pédagogique qui est très
important pour nous qu'il se dise bah
tiens il ya peut-être des solutions au
niveau du développement durable au
niveau de la défense de l'environnement
et qu'ils prennent conscience de tous
ces enjeux si l'expérience est
concluante sur cette première année le
puits de carbone devrait être renouvelée
à part la ville à l'une de ses valeurs
c'est justement l'écologie l'habitat
participatif se développe aujourd'hui on
dénombre environ à 500 projets en france
pendant tout le mois de mai ce sont les
portes ouvertes européenne de l'habitat
participatif
c'est l'occasion pour l'un de ses
projets de faire le point sur son
avancement on va en parler avec deux
invités qui nous rejoignent actuellement
en plateau nous avons acquis mme camara
bonsoir hassan casalta marc parent dont
hassan kamar bonsoir et nous avons
pascaline rodier bonsoir donc vous serez
deux futurs habitants vous êtes de
futurs habitants de ce projet qui
s'appelle à tintamarre un projet à
d'habitat participatif qui accueillera
donc dès 2020 ses premiers habitants
juste pour qu'on donne déjà toutes les
clés aux téléspectateurs redéfinir
peut-être ce qui est l'habitat
participatif
or l'une des particularité c'est que les
habitants prennent part directement à la
conception et est finalement à toutes
les phases du projet absolument donc
c'est une
c'est une démarche citoyenne en fait
d'abord qui permet à un groupe de
s'associer et de participer dans la
conception de leur logement est
également dans la conception de tout ce
qui est commun au groupe par la suite et
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle cela le
l'habitat participatif mais il ya
d'autres termes qui qualifient également
seul habitat c'est le habitat groupé
l'habitat coopératif et c'est un certain
nombre de termes mais le terme qui prend
le pied actuellement c'est l'habitat
participatif et l'idée aussi voilà c'est
de faire coexister au sein de cet
habitat participative des espaces qu'on
va dire privatif et aussi des espaces
partagés
c'est ça tout à fait dans le le projet
est prévu une dit maison commune mais
c'est une salle qui sera commune aux
groupes où l'on pourra et le groupe se
réunir et organiser des activités et
avec le quartier où certaines personnes
du groupe si elles veulent enfin on a
pensé un moment donné comme il ya une
mare au sein de tintamarre passé nous
avions vu le nombre de malades même
peut-être
invité des écoles pour découvrir la
biodiversité de la mare ou enfin tout et
tout est possible vous avez parlé d' une
notion importante celle du groupe parce
que vous êtes regrouper en groupes
depuis 2014 2014 c'est l'année où était
vraiment lancé le projet tintamarre
alors absolument
je dois préciser d'abord que c'est une
initiative de la mairie de la verrière 1
c'est la mairie de la verrière qui a
souhaité que ce projet là sur cette
parcelle qui est la plus belle en fait
par celle de la de la verrière 1 au sein
de du village voilà donc le quartier
villa du village et en face du parc de
la mgen qui est qu un par classe et donc
à souhaiter que ce projet là soit un
projet participatif et que ça se voit
aussi une expérience si vous voulez pour
le futur et éventuellement quartier
l'éco-quartier que garbi cannes voilà
donc et du coup donc c'est une
initiative vraiment qui vient de là de
la mairie est-ce que grâce à ce procédé
les les coûts aussi son réduit les coûts
du projet pour l'habitat participatif le
fait de voilà de se consulter avant
enfin c'est ce que ce procédé réduit les
coûts absolument donc déjà par exemple
au niveau du foncier la mairie a fait un
effort conséquent justement pour céder
le foncier à un autre promoteur qui est
un promoteur social copie mots
et donc déjà une participation elle a
également payé un bureau d'étude
justement pour nous accompagner parce
que l'habitat participatif c'est vrai
que c'est aussi simple pour les partis
cités mais il faut avoir les compétences
pour pouvoir amener des informations
choisir par exemple le montage le type
de montage juridique chercher des
financements etc
les habitants sont propriétaires sur sur
l'habitat participatif pour ce projet
oui oui donc c'était un projet de qui a
un montage sociale cps est là donc c'est
prêt social accession location
donc ça veut dire qu'on est au départ
locataires et puis après au bout de six
mois on peut lever l'option où on peut
éventuellement la louve et à partir de
six mois ou jusqu'à 4 en voilà ce sont
dix sept logements qui seront construits
des habitants qui vont venir vivre vous
êtes deux futurs habitants où en est le
projet aujourd'hui où on en est on en
est on on doit être déposé et
normalement la fin du mois le permis de
construire
on a un ça va être un peu retardé du
fait du ps paie lui qui est devenu p
juillet enfin bref en plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal à douala ce
projet a été ralentie il a repris elle a
repris sa route
oui parce qu'il ya eu un recours
justement sur le pea lui qui a été qui
est y met en place et donc du coup le
conseil d'état a dû terminer donc nous
nous étions pas concerné par pour ce
projet par par le recours est donc du
coup on pourrait éventuellement déposer
le permis de construire selon le ps lui
donc première livraison prévue en 2020
c'est ça 2020 exactement et donc c'est
une parcelle qui fait 4000 mètres carrés
avec une mare donc
2 600 m² à peu près qui était classé
d'ailleurs et nous souhaitons justement
cette mare est au tour de l'ensemble des
habitants seraient autour de la mare
donc du coup ça permet de donner enfin
une zone humide qui est qui sera aussi
aménagé réaménagé dans le cadre du
projet on aspect écologique on l'a
compris puisque je me reste aujourd'hui
ça va être ma dernière question des
logements disponibles et ce que des
personnes intéressées peuvent se joindre
rejoindre votre projet absolument donc
nous avons encore nous sommes déjà à la
recherche de dunes 8 familles à peu près
nous sommes actuellement huit familles
ferme donc inscrit 10 presque 10 très
bien parce qu'il ya des nouveaux
accédants qui arrivent mais si vous
savez donc ça le projet participatif
c'est un projet à longue haleine donc ça
veut dire que il ya des personnes qui
rentrent dans le projet et puis après au
sort parce que justement ils peuvent pas
attendre deux ans trois ans pour avoir
un logement et donc du coup il ya un
renouvellement si vous voulez au sein du
projet pendant en fait un projet
d'habitat participatif généralement dure
cinq ans minimum vingt cinq ans depuis
la conception jusqu'à la sortie des
bâtiments de terre et donc du coup c'est
vraiment un travail
comment dire il faut être vraiment
motivés voilà de longue haleine il faut
vraiment être motivé pour participer à
ce genre de projet
qui est très intéressant quand même
parce que pour l'intérêt de demander de
conclure ce qu'on a dit là c'est le
temps de l'entretien juste en fait je
voulais préciser quels quels sont les
avantages en fait l'intérêt de la vie
dans l'espace ils vous invitent à
renvoyer on va renvoyer au site internet
ce qu'on a on a même relevé passer le
temps d'entretien le site internet qui
s'affiche à l'écran pour retrouver
toutes les informations prendre
peut-être contact avec vous et donc je
vous remercie et merci beaucoup je
rappelle vos noms donc pascaline rodier
assane thiam a remercié d'avoir est avec
vous serez donc deux futurs habitants de
ce quartier donc tintamarre cet habitat
participatif merci beaucoup
tamare point fr pour et contact merci
voilà un mot de sport c'était une grande
première à guyancourt le club local de
kung fu à organiser une coupe de france
pour les jeunes le week-end dernier
au programme démonstrations et passage
devant un jury retour sur l'événement
avec michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry parfum d'asie flotter ce samedi
19 et dimanche 20 mai au gymnase des
droits de l'homme à guyancourt
l'enceinte sportive accueillait pour la
toute première fois une coupe de france
de kung fu pour les jeunes rendez vous
qui a attiré 3 160 compétiteurs ils ont
fait la compétition dans les différentes
régions et ensuite ils ont été qualifiés
à dire ceux qui sont qualifiés souvienne
pour les championnats pour la coupe de
france le jeune est donc là ils viennent
de toute la france et même d'autres
maires de qui viennent de martinique et
de guadeloupe de corse ou si nous avons
donc on a nous avons tous la france
aimez et dom tom qui sont représentés
aujourd'hui sur les tatamis tous les
participants doivent impressionner les
juges avec des figures réalisées sur
plusieurs minutes
nous avons une représentativité de la
pratique qui se fait en france des
styles traditionnels du stylet mise
comme un palestine limitative comme le
tigre lesage la mante religieuse
nous avons des styles comme le style de
charline aussi qu'ils sont entrés
répondu qu'ils sont connus à travers le
tour de charline ça c'est les styles à
manu après nous avons style mais stylée
les formats avec arme des techniques que
les jeunes billancourt toit du ckw
dragon loire le club organisateur
connaissent par coeur
plusieurs personnes qui viennent nous
attaquer à la fois du coup il faut les
combattre tous on donne un coup de pied
dans la cheville où on donne deux coupes
ans d'affilée dans la tête
sinon on fait un saut on donne on donne
un coup de pied là et le pied il vient
là pour claquer la coupe de france des
jeunes pourrait revenir en 2019 à vue en
cours le club devrait à nouveau se
porter candidat auprès de la fédération
française
[Musique]
un petit voyage dans le temps à présent
le week-end dernier le château de
breteuil proposait de découvrir le
domaine tel qu'il était en 1900 une
reconstitution historique avec un défilé
de l'élégance auquel ont assisté camille
lambert et nicolas ben driss
chapeau chargé de plumes ou de fleurs
dentelle et ombrelles pour les femmes
chapeau haut de forme gants et cannes
pour les hommes
le temps d'une journée le château de
breteuil s'est retrouvé plongé à la mode
de la belle époque
breteuil en 1907 une période de grands
changements
une véritable effervescence s'empare du
château déjà il ya des travaux
considérables dans le château on apporte
tout le confort moderne
henri duchesne un célèbre paysagiste va
transformer les jardins à la française
le parc à l'anglais est en quelque sorte
l'aspect du château tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui
eh bien on le doit tous ces travaux du
début du 20e siècle
une reconstitution pour rendre
l'histoire vivante
l'occasion de découvrir un patrimoine
culturel les 40 figurants et échanger
avec le public pour présenter leurs
tenues parfois venus de toute l'europe
et donc là nous avons l'ecosse avec nous
se sont rendus chez le marquis de
breteuil donc il était habillé en
conséquence donc c'était les grands
chapeaux à plumes les blouses blanches
et les grandes
les grandes jupes ces détenus qui ont
vocation à ce que les femmes puissent
marcher avec et donc ses étudiants une
tenue d'une d'une femme de la pub la
bourgeoisie assez aisée voilà qui part
en promenade pour un pique nique ce que
nous avons fait aujourd'hui de visiter
le château de voir toutes ces belles
choses et puis de voir ces gens là c'est
des costumes magnifiques et vraiment on
est dans l'ambiance et on oublie qu'on
est en 2018
un défilé de l'élégance pour un bond
dans l'histoire
un autre voyage est prévu le 3 juin
cette fois au carnaval de venise avant
de revenir au présent de vous laisser
avec le 7-8 culture de mélanie poquet
des véhicules anciens ont investi les
rues de rambouillet dimanche dernier
c'était la huitième édition de la bourse
des changes
rétro auto moto manon varaldo nicolas
bendriss entendre le bruit du moteur
prendre soin de sa voiture jusqu'à la
faire importer certains exposants sont
épris de leurs véhicules de collection
c'est un véhicule qui vient des états
unis de los angeles qui est de 96 g les
rapatrier directement via par
l'allemagne et donc ensuite je les
restaurer c'est un véhicule qui est
resté douze ans dans le département de
la police une passion dévorante pour les
voitures à l'image de lidié son mari
propriétaire d'une chevrolet coupé elle
est vraiment notre jeu on n'a pas touché
à la peinture ni à ses flammes tout tout
est d'origine
une passion qui s'étend également pour
son univers notre passion c'est tout ce
qu'est années 50-60 de rockabilly le
rock'n'roll
voilà tous les chanteurs de ces
années-là quoi c'est notre passion de
maison allait aller dans la collection
aussi avec donc c'est vraiment dans
notre corps quoi c'est notre patrie
dans nos veines les chineurs de pièces
automobiles étaient au rendez vous pour
cette bourse d'échangés organisée par
l'association le rendez-vous de la reine
on a une cinquantaine d'exposants voilà
et les gens viennent pour vendre des
pièces exposées aussi des voitures
anciennes
notre club date de 2008 qu on arrive
toujours des fois trouvé des choses
qu'on trouve pas ailleurs des
enjoliveurs des rétros petit support
d'interrupteurs des petites choses comme
ça quoi voilà peut-être pas neuf mais
bon qui en bon état pas ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'échanger avec les
propriétaires et puis de trouver la
petite merveille qu'on va pouvoir
rajouter notre collection amateurs de
véhicules anciens si vous désirez
agrandir votre collection rendez vous
l'an prochain
c'est la fin de ce journal très bonne
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]